there is no graceful way to get up to
this desk hello and welcome everyone to
the set of my brand new YouTube show
serial time please watch serial time and
can probably end the video there for one
or two not going to gonna keep talking
the show is essentially a bit of hybrids
between like breakfast morning radio and
the kind of videos you've come to expect
from YouTube vloggers don't know I ended
up there I think I've just really
nervous about talking about the show
because it's been a long time coming
each episode is gonna be about 10 to 15
minutes long it's gonna be going up
every single weekday morning and it's
gonna be the kind of content that you
can hopefully just leave on in the
background while you're getting ready
for your day the idea for the show
actually originated from mr. Hank green
who is our executive producer which
sounds very fancy doesn't it basically
after I was done making my little series
of short films I was talking to Hank
about how he's just feeling quite unsure
what I wanted to do with myself and on
YouTube generally and I really wanted to
find a way where I could be more present
on YouTube without having to go down
that daily vlogging route which I kind
of although I do like watching some
daily vloggers I just don't enjoy the
process of filming my entire day it
really makes me feel like very
disconnected from my life and so the
idea of doing a show like this where I
get to be here every weekday but it's
still like a fun and creative thing to
do but it also doesn't get in the way of
my real life it just seemed like the
right fit speaking of daily vlogging
actually now that I've just said I
really don't like it I did film some
clips from behind the scenes of cereal
time when we were filming our first
episodes and that did turn out to be
pretty fun actually so here are those I
was about to film the first this is
historic
Emily was actually suggesting that we
should play some kind of game before we
get started oh okay yeah get off our
energy I don't know what we could do
there I used to be in a lot of places
and before we do any performance of the
play we'd have to do this really long
rhyme it's not even a rhyme it's like a
tongue twister I'll do it for you as
much as I can remember so it goes
Trinidad and the warm Mississippi and
the town Honolulu and the Lake Titicaca
the Poppa per capita is not in Canada
rather in Mexico Mexico Mexico Canada
Rimini Brindisi Canada málaga Rimini
Brindisi yes Tim better Tim better -
better oh yes
do better don't better - better so you
better remember that good morning I am
charlie I'm Jimmy and on today's show
babies both normal and regal but which
is which a cereal time that's how you do
in German yay now I am doing the show I
do also want to say that I have no plans
to slow down production on my own
channel if anything I hope to speed it
up the idea being that now that I have a
bit of structure in my life a bit of a
schedule hopefully that will encourage
me to be more regular on this channel
but we'll see how it goes no promises
and it's also a way of saying that this
is by no means just my show a lot of
people have worked on it to make it
happen and a page who made this set for
us which is just kind of amazing really
you don't Kieran O'Brien who did all of
the lighting for us Ouiser Odell who did
our awesome logo Halley Faust and Todd
Bryant in who did our graphics and music
for the show respectively Hank green
again for just making the whole thing
possible and maybe most importantly
Jimmy and Josh Jimmy for being my
co-host on the show and for coming on
this crazy journey with me and our
producer Josh who is essentially cereal
time like you just this is his full time
job which is pretty cool josh has been
working incredibly hard trying to make
this whole thing happen so thank you
very much for that sir and hopefully
I'll see you every weekday morning from
today until the end of my life we will
take breaks we will definitely take
breaks goodbye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like who
thank you very much for watching if you
would like to see my previous video
that's up there and if you would like to
watch please do the very first episode
of cereal time that's down there who
else can I say I just really hope that
you watch it have I not said that enough
already this video I probably have I
mean if you don't like it that is fine I
won't take it personally but I just
really hope you do and now I will sit
here and wait for you to click on it I'm
willing you please I did my best at
least I could say that goodbye